the jurogan experience i think we talked
about this before in relation to the
communist era in eastern europe
that that with that sort of part of the
point that
you the humiliation of going along with
things you know aren't true
ends up having an effect down the road
because you just
nod anything along
yeah i have a friend who grew up mormon
and one thing she said to me once it was
really interesting she said uh because
she left the church
and she said i'm i'm really susceptible
to [ __ ] it's a real problem wow and
so she started
like she had gotten mixed up with some
like yogi type people and guru type
people right people that were running
like these weird little sort of like
self-help things that were very
cult-like and she goes i have a real
problem i'm very susceptible she goes
because i i grew up
agreeing to things that are nonsensical
and because of that because i had just
like given all of my
you know what when you when you just
like all of your opinions are decided by
a church and the church was written by a
14 year old boy in 1820 yeah like it's
it's kind of nuts yeah and that already
had a conviction for fraud yeah he was
already full [ __ ] at 14.
that was a giveaway yeah it was a
definite giveaway well it's i mean the
just if you read the tenets of the
religion first of all they're wonderful
people mormons are so yeah i agree i
agree i don't like beating up on mormons
because they're so nice yeah it's like
actually if if there were more mormons
right it wouldn't be so bad you know if
you could just take out the crazy yeah
you got a good religion yeah um i uh
wow how much crazy anyway but that's
it's sort of the same principle sort of
applies to when people just accept you
know like with
woke-ism when you accept these
ideological givens that aren't logical
they don't make any sense i i wonder if
it's the same with societies you know i
think that uh
it's a thing like post-religious peoples
just because you've lost the religion
doesn't mean you've lost the religious
instinct right
you're still looking for it it seems
like that's an inherent part of being a
person i agree and i i don't think i
don't say it's bad it's just it is part
of what we are and uh
it seems to me very clear that for
instance you know you take
christianity out and other things will
be put in
and they don't even need to be
identifiable religions right uh
i mean our own age has decided in much
of the west that
there's this sort of form of
uh watered-down
spillover of christianity which will
become the sort of religion
which is the kind of diversity inclusion
equity world
where you constantly struggle for
greater justice
all of which is a sort of very watered
down version of a little bit of
christianity there's a clear genesis of
that too in the the woke world there was
a a group at a certain point in time do
you remember when the atheist movement
had hit this atheist plus movement
do you remember atheism plus what was
that
it was weird and it was a bunch of these
weird virtue signaling male feminist
types that were adding with atheism
adding a a group of core values
oh wow about you know being
anti-discrimination
anti-sexist anti-racist
their own ten commandments yes and so
they they called it atheism plus and i
remember watching this guy give this
speech this [ __ ] boring speech on
this
sort of establishing this
this idea that
because you don't have a religion
um so we're going to be atheists but
with plus we can establish sort of a
moral framework well
it's totally understandable uh and a
disaster of course
at most
even if the ideas are good it's like
you're putting it in an ideology you're
you're creating a dog you're creating a
all those new atheists who sort of
started in the 2000 friend sam harris
and others
they in my experience they all got a
little bit nervous about the what was on
their shoulders
christopher hitchens certainly did he
started i think
lately in his life to get a little bit
nervous about what was happening i
remember once asking him what
what about it he said people were
starting to ask him to officiate at
their weddings oh yeah and that was like
he he didn't say
anything of what he said was wrong he
still obviously believed everything he
believed but like that's a slightly
troubling
place to be in because you start to
sense people are wanting you to replace
the vicar
the priest and that's
and that's not the point then you're in
life of brian territory aren't you like
you know i want you know you should all
think for yourselves yes we all think
for ourselves it's
it it was always a problem of atheism or
like it was an invitation to
to not do one thing yeah but it didn't
but nothing follows from it as to how
you should live your life and
if it's the start of something is not by
any means a
beginning of a policy do you think
that's just an inherent
thing about being a tribal primate that
we have this desire to have someone
wiser a leader and then even better if
you can have like a godlike figure who
gives you a set of rules that you have
to follow are there horrendous
consequences and it keeps everyone in
line yeah absolutely i always um
in the 2000s i started to think
if somebody came along and declared
prophethood
at the moment
well they could do quite well
i mean think of those those hucksters on
u.s television who still
still take money from people
saying that they can only build the
church and have their helicopter if you
send in your dollars you know
uh those people still exist there's a
guy who's still selling his like silver
water that he blesses from the river
jordan or something it comes out some
hoses
yeah and there are people who've been
busted repeatedly and they're still uh
they're still selling their wares um i i
i always thought yeah if somebody
actually made the profit claim in our
era
i think people would be
surprised how many
people would go along with it it's what
it's the late george steiner um
described
a phrase i love the nostalgia for the
absolute
i love that phrase a nostalgia for the
absolute i think i think a lot of people
have it i have it we all have it to some
extent and the question is whether you
can avoid it
taking you to places that um
would demoralize you and lead you to a
bad place
yeah it's
i think
if someone came along and had a really
good cult like a real solid cult like
really welled out well laid out be
rational
think for yourself be kind examine all
evidence like
people would join into that and then it
would yeah it always ends up with like
massive orgy doesn't it yes it does it
always says
you got to give me all your money you
have to [ __ ] your life exactly like wild
wild countries like oh it's all about
peace and it's like nah you get a school
of women wild wild country is amazing
that documentary's so good i love that
that guy oh show had some really
interesting you still see his um books
in some places like in the netherlands a
little while ago they had his books
still in the bookshops you can buy them
on apple on uh on on the apple bookstore
i've read a couple of them i do like
that bit where he says he says in one of
his speeches yeah the people people are
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
by the people for the people of the
people
but the problem is the people are
[ __ ]
it should be by the [ __ ]
for the [ __ ] it's like oh my god
a guru is saying that
and there's something about the fact
that he's dead now and then yeah he said
it decades ago it's like but we are fine
we are searching for for four things at
the moment yeah and it seems very
obvious to me i mean you know what
plenty of people have called them like
things like the religion of anti-racism
the religion of social justice all that
stuff
they are all something to do you know
yes uh some
very very deep level like you've had
your purpose today like you've had your
five fruit and veg you've had your
meaning yeah you've had your meaning